juge martin boswell
donc tu as 64 ans
maintenant tu reçois toujours un valentine pour l'
anniversaire
des garçons ouais tu fais j'ai eu un très
beau message de paul
ouais quand j'avais 64 ans. ouais une bouteille de
vin et une salutation d'anniversaire
j'étais obligé de  te dire que tu sais que
tu es
célèbre dans le monde entier et pour toujours en
tant que producteur des beatles mais
très peu de gens savent qu'en 69 tu as
commencé un studio à londres
appelé air studio et 10 ans plus tard
un autre studio
à montserrat dans les caraïbes appelé
air studio montserrat belle île
assez petit
très près d'une de vos îles bayonetta
guadalupe
c'est très montagneux
et il pleut beaucoup mais surtout la nuit
du 17 septembre 89
il y a eu un ouragan dans les caraïbes
et 12 000 personnes ont tout perdu
dans l'île maintenant  était une
dévastation complète j'y
suis allé dès que j'ai pu ouais
parce que pendant la première semaine nous ne pouvions même pas
parler à personne parce que l'ouragan a
rendu tout le monde sans abri le port était
de  détruit
l'hôpital avait perdu la moitié de ses
salles et même la
génération de toute l'électricité est allée sur toute l'
île pas d'électricité
nous n'avions pas d'électricité pendant deux
mois tout était juste
et votre studio était hors d'usage de
savoir que notre studio ne fonctionnait pas
depuis lors
parce que même si le studio lui-même euh
était bien construit
ouais euh néanmoins nous n'avions pas d'électricité pas
de climatisation
et l'île n'est pas là-dedans ce n'était pas
un état d'avoir
des stars célèbres là-bas ouais tu sais si mick
jagger y va il veut un  un peu
de confort ouais et il n'y a pas d'entreprise
là-bas en ce moment
donc vous avez décidé de lever des fonds et vous avez
décidé de vendre un disque
un album et vous avez demandé des numéros à
différents magasins
paul mccartney bien sûr
simplement rouge moyen la pierre roulante
vous a donné quelque chose de spécial maintenant
eh bien, ils m'ont donné l'un des morceaux qu'ils
n'avaient pas réellement publiés eux-mêmes,
ce qui était très gentil de leur part parce qu'ils ont
fait leur album
l'année dernière ouais pas très longtemps avant le
hur  ricane à montserrat
et quand j'ai entendu parler de la catastrophe j'ai dit
eh bien je suis sûr que tout le monde veut aider les
habitants de l'île
qui ont tout perdu et j'ai contacté
chaque artiste et tout le monde a dit bien sûr
nous allons donner une piste  donc sur le disque il y a
une piste que chaque artiste a faite
sur l'île ouais
dio détroit moi boy jaws joran duran
status core
alors parlons de ta vie maintenant
qu'as-tu fait
avant de payer la facture alors les
beatles t'ont bien rencontré
j'étais déjà producteur de disques depuis 12
ans
mais je dirigeais euh le
label polyphone ouais en angleterre ouais
et un petit label donc j'ai tout fait
et c'était une branche de ton esprit
une branche d'emi mais c'était un tout petit
label anglais
et j'ai dû tout enregistrer, du jazz
musique classique musique populaire tout
et j'ai décidé de me spécialiser dans les
disques de comédie
et j'ai eu un impact pour commencer j'étais
connu en tant que producteur de comédie
c'est pourquoi vous vous en souvenez peter selass ou
peter justina
c'est  droite et flandre et schwann
et
dudley moore et peter cook
et j'ai fait une réputation pour ça et en
fait quand les beatles sont arrivés
ouais c'était l'une des raisons pour lesquelles nous nous
entendions si bien ensemble
parce que pour eux j'étais célèbre parce que j'ai
fait tout  ces disques qu'ils l'
aimaient et
ils pensaient qu'ils s'amuseraient
peut-être pas bien avec toi
et ils avaient aussi le même genre d'
humour qu'eux
ils avaient ce type bizarre euh loufoque de
ouais j'aimerais savoir comment tu t'es fait  en
contact avec eux la première fois que
c'est par vous, vous avez reçu un appel téléphonique
d'un gars appelé sid coleman à
propos d'un autre gars appelé brian epstein
et vous avez décidé de les rencontrer
ce qui s'est passé bien brown avait été
dans toutes les maisons de disques du pays
et je n'ai pas '
Je ne le sais pas en fait si je l'avais su je ne suis pas sûr que je l'
aurais pris mais de toute façon
je ne le savais pas ils ont été refusés
par deca pie phillips tout le
monde tout le monde même même emi ouais
et les deux personnes en emi  les avait
refusés
eh bien, apparemment, il est allé au
magasin d'Oxford Street
pour faire couper des disques à partir de bandes
qu'il avait
afin qu'il puisse toujours essayer d'obtenir de l'
action et l'
homme qui a écouté le disque et a dit
pourquoi ne pas les amener à sid coleman
il était un éditeur de musique
et donc il est allé carmen seasid et sitcom
et a dit à
qui les avez-vous montrés à ryan a récité
toutes
les personnes qu'il a dit valait à peu près tout le
monde il a dit avez-vous essayé george
martin
il a dit non qui est george martin il a dit
bien il est un  mec qui a la
réputation de faire un truc insolite
et
sur polyphon et j'étais le genre de farceur
de la meute de voitures
tu comprends j'étais le fond du
parc
et il est venu me voir et j'ai écouté
ce qu'il avait
qu'est ce que tu as fait  pense vraiment que la première fois que
tu as entendu son euh
eh bien c'étaient de très mauvais disques ouais donc
je me suis senti désolé pour les gens plus tard qui les
refuseraient
mais il y avait quelque chose là-bas que je
pensais être intéressant
et je cherchais quelque chose de toute
façon  aide je ne peux pas juger sur ce point je vais
devoir les voir et je dois travailler avec
eux
avant de pouvoir me décider et vous lui demandez
de les faire venir de hambourg où
ils jouaient dans
le star club célèbre star club  à toi
juste pour passer une audition
dans une rue de la baie nous sommes venus à Abbey Road ouais
et
j'ai passé une soirée avec eux ouais et je suis
tombé amoureux d'eux
ouais coup de foudre tu dis aimer une
personne ouais
et qu'est-ce qu'ils ont joué  pour toi la première
fois
eh bien des chansons très ennuyeuses en fait
euh je pense bien ils ont joué adorablement ouais
ils ont aussi joué des trucs comme
sur l'arc-en-ciel ouais
ouais ouais et donc
ils n'ont pas montré à ce moment-là qu'ils
pouvaient être de grands compositeurs
rien qu'ils n'aient écrit  ouais c'était
très bien mon amour, c'était à peu près le meilleur
qu'ils avaient,
ils avaient une version de s'il vous plaît, s'il vous
plaît, mais c'était très lent
comme roy évidemment très lent
et euh alors aime-moi, je l'ai choisi le
premier
tu dis que George était  le plus
bavard après le premier
enregistrement ouais je  bien pensé peut-être que je
n'obtiens pas ce son comme ils
pensent qu'il devrait être
alors je les ai amenés dans la salle de contrôle
j'ai dit regardez écoutez ça
et s'il y a quelque chose que vous n'aimez pas
faites le moi savoir ouais et george george
s'est tourné  à moi et m'a dit
bien pour commencer je n'aime pas ton temps
battu mieux toi tu pensais qu'il n'était pas un
bon bon batteur
tu voulais en avoir un autre et
tu as pensé à un pro un gars qui s'appelle ndy
et ils t'ont présenté  ils vous ont présenté
ringo starr et
pourquoi avez-vous choisi star à la fin
au lieu de
votre gars et dwight eh bien je n'ai pas
le truc c'est que je ne voulais pas
sauter de la poêle à frire dans le feu
tu comprends ouais et je  Je savais que
je devais trouver un meilleur batteur que Pete,
donc Andy White était un habitué, il était le
meilleur
musicien de session quand Ringo est arrivé, je
ne le connaissais pas du tout
et j'ai donc dit aux garçons, regardez, il est peut-être
bon, mais pour autant.  en ce qui me concerne,
j'ai ce type pour lequel nous payons de l'argent
, utilisons-le mais alors w  quand ringo a
commencé à jouer
euh il avait un son distinctif et il
s'intégrait très bien
mais il ne m'a jamais pardonné de ne pas l'avoir
laissé jouer lors de cette première session
il me tient toujours tête ouais le
problème était de savoir qui sera le
leader de  le groupe
parce que vous ne saviez pas parmi eux qui
sera le leader et vous avez décidé de
les voir jouer dans la caverne à
liverpool oui bien sûr j'ai vu tout ce qu'ils ont fait dans
la caverne
n'oubliez pas à cette époque les groupes
qui existaient
étaient  concentré autour d'une personne comme
cliff richard et les ombres ouais
et c'était inhabituel d'avoir un groupe qui
était
démocratique si vous aimez ouais mais
quand j'étais à liverpool j'ai
réalisé que le groupe
ne devrait pas être changé ils étaient morts à
droite  tels qu'ils étaient
et il était évident que celui qui a écrit
la chanson
alors ils ont proposé votre chanson et chaque
fois que vous dites que je veux plus je veux
plus et ils sont venus avec un de moi à vous
avec
elle vous aime et vous avez dit qu'ils étaient un
puits sans fond  de chansons y  ous avez découvert qu'ils étaient de
très bons auteurs-compositeurs maintenant
très rapidement le succès en fait le succès les a
aidés
ouais ça leur a fait réaliser qu'ils devaient
travailler plus dur
ouais et c'était comme mettre une
petite plante dans une serre et allumer la
lumière du soleil
ils ont soudainement fleuri et ils étaient
merveilleux
ça  première année fantastique tu es venu à
paris avec eux
pour l'olympia parce qu'ils devaient
enregistrer des chansons en allemagne je suis allé dans tout l'
iran et elle t'a aimé en allemand
parce que ima en allemagne voulait qu'ils
chantent en allemand
et quand tu étais à paris tu as
appris
que le disque était numéro un aux
États-Unis
et que vous êtes venu en Géorgie cinq il y
avait une fête
bien c'était une période très excitante tout d'
abord les beatles ne voulaient pas enregistrer
dans une langue étrangère n'importe où ouais et
ils pensaient que c'était idiot
ouais  et ils avaient tout à fait raison en fait
mais les allemands ont insisté pour que nous le fassions
et pour commencer ils ne voulaient pas le
faire ils apparaissaient
à l'olympia et
quand le moment est venu de  je les
attendais pour faire cet enregistrement, ils ne se sont
pas présentés
et j'étais aux studios en les attendant et
j'ai continué à regarder à distance ce qui s'est passé
vous savez qu'ils ne se sont pas présentés
j'ai appelé le george sack j'ai parlé à neil
aspinall  qui était là
directeur de la route directeur de la route et il a dit
bien je suis désolé george mais ils diraient
qu'ils ne viennent pas
j'ai dit que tu dois leur dire que je les
veux ici en ce moment et je n'ai pas
de bêtises
et il a dit  Eh bien, vous devrez leur
dire vous-même, alors je suis monté dans le taxi et je
suis retourné à Georgetown.
Je suis monté dans leur appartement.
la table avec
la petite amie de jane asher paul elle était là en
train de verser du thé et c'était comme une scène d'
alice au pays des merveilles ouais et dès que
je suis entré dans la porte, ils ont tous
couru dans tous les coins de la pièce
et ont mis des coussins sur leurs têtes
et  ici l'a fait et a prétendu qu'ils avaient
peur
et que vous pouviez  ne soyez pas en colère contre eux pendant
longtemps vous savez qu'ils étaient si charmants
et ils sont venus dans les studios et nous avons fait
le travail mais ils avaient tout à fait raison nous
ne devrions pas
vous avez été très impliqué et essentiel dans
la transition
du rock and roll à la pop  de la musique à
la pop progressive
et tu leur as fait découvrir de nouveaux
instruments pour eux comme des
instruments classiques par exemple et on peut l'
entendre sur
eleanor rigby car quand tu
enregistrais de la musique classique tu étais
spécialisé dans le baroque non
ils avaient une éternelle curiosité ouais ils ont
toujours voulu trouver  plus
et ils me disaient toujours donne
moi de nouvelles chansons qu'est ce que tu as
qu'est ce qu'un orchestre classique et
je leur donnerais donne leur ce que je savais
ouais et quand il s'agissait de penny lane
paul avait entendu un concerto de bach brandebourg
et il est venu  aux jours suivants et j'ai
entendu un son fantastique la nuit dernière
c'était un morceau d'écorce j'ai dit que c'était
une trompette très haute
vous
leur avez présenté de nouvelles techniques d'enregistrement comme
euh
la bande inversée demain ne
sait jamais
bien j'expérimentais toujours à cette
époque parce que
nous n'avions pas de synthétiseurs un produit d'
aujourd'hui
et si nous devions faire des sons bizarres nous
devions faire  nous
-mêmes et la seule façon de le faire était de
jouer comme
tant de gens l'ont fait depuis dans
leurs propres enregistreurs
et je ferais toutes sortes de découpes
de bandes et de les remonter
et John vous a dit euh à chaque fois prends
soin de toi
parce que je ne sais pas que c'est pour les
champs de fraises pour toujours euh il voulait garder la
première partie d'une chanson et la deuxième
partie de l'autre prise disons
que c'est vrai
et tu dis prends soin de ça et toi tu l'as
pas
bien géré  le problème avec les deux morceaux
qu'il voulait assembler était qu'ils
étaient
dans des tonalités différentes ouais et dans des
hauteurs différentes, mais en faisant
glisser les vitesses, j'ai pu
les réunir alors que quatre
pistes se
produisaient  ng aussi vous savez ouais et vous avez fait
le papier sergent avec seulement quatre pistes
comment avez-vous réussi à le faire euh je
n'aurais pas pu le faire autrement
parce que c'est tout c'était ouais vous savez
si j'avais eu 16 pistes ou 24  ou 48 titres
je les aurais utilisés mais je n'avais que
quatre titres
donc c'est comme ça que j'ai fait c'est pas si mal
et tu les as beaucoup aidés car ils
sont venus vers toi avec des embryons de chansons ou de la matière
première et tu les aides à faire des
chansons définitives  trop bien cela faisait partie
du processus qui fait
partie du processus aujourd'hui d'être un
bon producteur pour être
quelqu'un en qui l'artiste peut avoir confiance
qui donnera une opinion qui est vraie
parce que si vous êtes très célèbre et que vous
êtes un grand auteur
-compositeur et  tu travailles pour quelqu'un et tu es
très célèbre ils diront que c'est fantastique
ouais les
gens ont peur de dire que je pense que ça peut
être mieux
et c'est ce qu'un producteur doit faire donc
tu les as toi tu as joué toi-même
des instruments ouais j'ai joué avec
claviers claviers que j'utilisais pour jouer du
hautbois
il y a de nombreuses années comment avez-vous été payé avez-vous
reçu des honoraires ou des redevances
comment avez-vous été payé sur ces disques mal
mal
euh non pour commencer j'étais un membre du personnel d'emr
donc tout ce que j'ai obtenu était de 3 200 livres par an
pas beaucoup pas de voiture  pas de
redevances non pas de commission,
c'est vraiment pourquoi je suis parti en 65
et j'ai créé ma propre entreprise
, puis j'ai reçu des redevances et vous avez eu des
problèmes plus tard lorsque vous avez enregistré le
mccartney avec imai, vous savez
de quelle manière ils ont dit sur
votre  contrat
vous devez enregistrer les beatles vous avez
raison et vous avez dit qu'ils se sont séparés
mais ils disent non c'est un ça s'appelle
mccartney c'est bien
parce que quand nous avons négocié un accord pour les
royalties des beatles c'était un très petit
montant c'était
20 pour un penny ouais seulement  très petite
quantité ouais
et quand je suis venu enregistrer mccartney, ils ont
dit que vous aviez dit que vous enregistreriez que
vous garantissiez d'enregistrer les beatles
ouais et c'est le même taux
mais euh je me suis disputé avec ça
avez-vous vécu leur
séparation c'était une période difficile et bec  Parce qu'ils
étaient mécontents l'un de l'autre
et que c'était le pire moment de tous, c'était
parce que je pensais vraiment que c'était la
fin de la route parce qu'ils se
disputaient tout le temps
et euh les femmes n'aidaient pas
et j'étais assez surpris  après que ce
soit
quand paul m'a appelé et a dit que nous
aimerions faire un autre disque avec vous
qui était et j'ai dit eh bien je ne le ferai
que si nous le faisons comme nous l'avons fait avant
avec une production appropriée et il a dit nous '
je le ferai
donc nous avons fini sur la route de l'abbaye et
c'était très heureux que
nous nous entendions tous bien ensemble le côté deux est
fantastique le
côté deux de la corde de bébé était ce que j'avais
toujours voulu faire
après Peppa pour faire une sorte de champ symphonique
et John  je ne voulais pas faire ça john
voulait un
disque de rock and roll donc quand on a fait abby road c'était un
compromis d'
un côté c'était ce que je voulais faire avec l'
esprit de john et de l'autre c'était
toi et paul meinde comment tu as fait
apprendre
la mort de john euh où es-tu j'étais
à la maison et c'était tôt le matin
six heures du matin et je
devais aller au studio
parce que je travaillais avec paul
mccartney sur tug of war
et j'ai entendu la nouvelle et j'ai immédiatement
appelé paul chez lui
et j'ai dit que je ne suppose pas que tu veuilles
entrer aujourd'hui préférez-vous
ne pas travailler aujourd'hui il a dit je
ne peux pas rester ici je dois venir
j'ai une porte alors nous avons convenu de nous rencontrer dans
le studio
et nous n'avons rien fait nous avons juste parlé
toute la journée à
propos de John et
nous l'avons en quelque sorte sorti de notre
système, c'était un choc terrible et
cela a aidé à pouvoir
se parler des bons moments
et c'était horrible
le seul si je peux te reprocher quelque chose
pourquoi as-tu accepté  pour diriger la partition musicale
du film sur papier du sergent produit par
robert stigwood
avec les beegees et peter frampton bonne
question ouais
euh c'était il avait toutes les références pour
être
bon parce que c'était une pièce
de théâtre à euh sur broadway
qui était extrêmement bien mise en scène et  un
vieil ami à moi appelé jim dale
qui est un broadway  le démarreur l'a vu et a
dit que c'était fantastique
et s'ils en faisaient un film ce serait
merveilleux
mais ce que je n'avais pas réalisé qu'une fois que j'ai
signé le contrat pour le faire
j'étais impliqué et je n'avais pas réalisé que
toutes les chansons qui étaient si  chers pour moi
allaient être enregistrés et je devais les
enregistrer avec des gens que je ne connaissais pas
ouais euh tu sais que c'était bouleversant
mais ils étaient c'est la vie tu
prends de bonnes décisions tu en prends de mauvaises et tu
rencontres toujours george et  ringo non
parfois je n'ai pas vu ringo depuis qu'il a
eu son petit sort en
ouais en amérique et j'ai vu george
récemment
ouais ils s'enflamment on parle encore de
temps en temps
mais je vois paul surtout qu'est-ce que les
beatles ont ajouté
que d'autres n'ont pas fait  Ce n'était pas dans vos yeux,
c'était les chansons, c'était les chansons étaient
des chansons brillantes
et elles avaient un puits de créativité que je
n'avais expérimenté chez personne d'autre,
elles étaient fantastiques et ce qu'auraient
été les Beatles
sans George Martin oh les Beatles
auraient  été les beatles je suis s
Je suis sûr que quelqu'un aurait pris peut-
être que ce n'était peut-être pas pareil, mais
ils auraient quand même été trop bons pour ne pas se
produire et ce qui aurait été
George Martin sans les Beatles,
probablement encore en train de faire un petit-déjeuner comique,
je ne  je ne sais pas
[Musique]
bleu